Over the next four lessons, we'll
discuss two very important problems.
Finding a maximum flow on a graph and
solving a linear
programming optimization.
These problems are P-complete, meaning
that any problem that can be solved on
a Turing machine in polynomial time, can
be turned into one of these problems.
We will also see an important restricted
case in the bipartite matching problem.
And then we'll explore the connections
among all these problems,
in a discussion of the principal of
duality, which is the inspiration for
a large class of
approximation algorithms.
In this first lesson,
we discuss the problem of finding
a maximum flow through a network.
A network here is essentially
anything that can be modeled
as a directive graph.
And by flow, we mean the movement
of some stuff through a medium,
from some designated
source to a destination.
Typically we want to maximize the flow.
That is to say,
we want to route as many packets
as possible from one computer
across a network to another, or
we want to ship as many items
from our factories to our stores.
Even if we don't actually want to move
as much as possible across the network,
understanding the maximum flow can
give us important information.
For instance, in communication networks,
it tells us something about how
robust we are to link failures.
And even more abstractly, maximum flow
problems can help us figure out things
that seem unrelated to networks.
Like, which teams have been eliminated
playoff contention in sports.
Given the variety and importance of
these applications, it should be no
surprise that maximum flow problems
have been studied extensively, and
we have some sophisticated and
elegant algorithms for solving them.
Let's dive in.